diese Linie die Putin zum Mitteln
greifen lässt die ganz Europa in Brand
stecken könnten
Diskussion um Kampfjets wie weit geht
der Westen jetzt der Phönix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
zugeschaltet ist uns Frau Professorin
Nicole deidelhoff für die Rektorin des
leibniz-instituts hessische Friedens und
Konfliktforschung in Frankfurt am Main
hier im Studio sind Sarah paguhn
Programmleiterin des Berliner Forums
Außenpolitik
unterhalten von der körperstiftung
mein Kollege Thomas Wiegold ist hier
Journalist und Militärexperte sie sind
auch Blogger und haben einen Block zum
Thema Bundeswehr und Militär mit dem
Titel Augen geradeaus und schließlich
Professor Alexander Liebmann
Politikwissenschaftler mit Schwerpunkt
Osteuropa und Russland an der Freien
Universität Berlin Frau deitelhoff nach
Kampfpanzern jetzt Kampfflugzeuge der
Kanzler spricht der genervt von einem
Überbietungswettbewerb lassen wir uns da
eine Diskussion aufzwingen jetzt sofort
auch über Flugzeuge für die Ukraine zu
entscheiden
also ich würde es mal so sagen aus der
Ukraine ist der Wunsch nach
Kampfflugzeugen völlig legitim man
versucht hier jede Unterstützung zu
bekommen die man bekommen kann aber aus
deutscher Sicht ist das momentan einfach
die falsche Debatte hier geht es darum
wie wir schnellstmöglich die Kampfpanzer
in die Ukraine bekommen können
würde der Westen mit der Lieferung von
Kampfjets für Putin endgültig zu
Kriegspartei
also wenn ich glaube das müssen wir
auseinander halten also Kriegspartei als
juristischer Begriff ist ein
völkerrechtlicher Begriff und da reicht
die Lieferung von Waffen unabhängig
davon welche ist sind nicht aus die
dahinter stehende Frage ist ja
betrachtet Russland uns Deutschland den
Westen als Teil dieses Konfliktes auch
Teil des Krieges und das muss man eben
sagen das ist so aber auch unabhängig
davon ob wir nur Flugabwehr liefern oder
auch Panzer oder auch Flugzeuge für
diese Eindruck verstärkt sich nicht
durch die Lieferung von Kampfjets das
sozusagen eine neue Qualität dann
darstellt also ich glaube diese diese
diese Eindruck diese auch
Betrachtungsweise Europas oder auch der
des Konfliktes mit dem besten ist ohne
hindern die russische Führung tut ja so
als könne keine westliche
Waffenlieferung sie aus der Ruhe bringen
als sei der Sie gewiss gilt das auch für
Kampfjets für die aus russischer Sicht
drohende Lieferung dieser Flugzeuge also
ich glaube es geht weniger um konkrete
Ausrüstung die geliefert werden sondern
mehr darum was mir diese Ausrüstung
gemacht wird sobald die Ukraine und mit
der Lieferung von Kampf Gesetz ist es
einfach deutlich wahrscheinlich und das
ist genau was das so gefährlich macht
die russischen roten Linien
überschreitet ganz konkret massive
Angriffe auf die Krim und auch auf die
militärischen Installation auf dem
russischen Territorium eigentlichen
Sinne dann kann tatsächlich es zum
europäischen Brand kommen
Deutschland ist ja wohl außen vor bei
den bei den Kampfjets wir brauchen sie
selbst wenn sie den einsatzfähig sind
ist das diese Diskussion eher eine die
die Amerikaner betrifft die Amerikaner
die Amerikaner und andere europäische
Verbündete also deutsche Tornados
deutsche Eurofighter auch wenn André
melden nicht sie erwähnt hat stehen ganz
offensichtlich nicht auf der Wunschliste
es geht um F16 die haben die USA die
haben die Niederländer die haben die
Polen also da muss man eher hingucken
Deutschland hat eine politische Rolle
und im Unterschied zu dem Panzern keine
praktische
Erfahrungen die zu beiden hat ja auf die
Frage ob er jetzt diese F16 die offenbar
geeignet sind für die Ukraine liefern
will ganz kurz gesagt no no
wie viele Halbwertszeit heißt die hat
dieses Nein oder ist das auf Dauer
ein bisschen unklar zu sein ob das
wirklich ein ein auf Dauer nein ist oder
nur ein aktuelles nein ich glaube aber
ehrlich gesagt dass man sowohl von
US-amerikanischer Seite als auch von
deutscher Seite gerade dieser
Debatte versucht abzuwiegeln weil sie
einfach nicht der Kern der Sache ist wir
sollten gerade eher darauf schauen wie
können wir die die Panzer vernünftig und
die Ukraine kriegen auch so dass das auf
Dauer erhaltbar ist mit entsprechender
Logistik Wartungsarbeiten vor allem der
Munitionsnachschub ist das zentrale
Problem ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht
dass wir uns einen Gefallen tun mit
dieser Debatte und auch wenn man ja
beispielsweise dem jetzigen ukrainischen
Botschafter hier in Berlin zu hat auch
er sagt das ist ja nicht die prior
Nummer eins ist also ich glaube da gehen
gerade in der Debatte auch die die
Pferde manchmal ein bisschen durchlaufen
und die falsche Richtung wir werden noch
darüber reden ob das eine Diskussion für
uns Zeit ist und was das für
Konsequenzen hat Frau die Ukraine will
ja diese F 16 Kampfflugzeuge haben jetzt
ist ja
Joe beiden genau in der gleichen Lage
wie Olaf Scholz bei den Kampfpanzer
Lieferungen da ging es eigentlich nur um
den Leopard das war das ist das
wichtigste Element jetzt hat beiden
diese Diskussion im Kampfflugzeuge am
Hals da geht es ja um zwei Aspekte
liefern also dass die Amerikaner direkt
liefern oder das sind ja hier schon
einige Länder genannt worden die F16
Kampfflugzeuge haben dass die Amerikaner
genehmigen müssen dass diese
Flugzeuge in die Ukraine kommen wenn man
sich das mal ansieht diese politische
Komplexität bleibt da Bewegung in der
Diskussion oder ist es tatsächlich
erstmal nur also entweder eine
Nebelkerze gewesen mit den
Kampfflugzeugen oder wollte man testen
wie zum Beispiel Putin reagiert
nein also ich glaube beiden hat da seine
Position sehr deutlich gemacht indem er
gesagt hat er ist nicht bereit
irgendwelche Waffensysteme zu liefern
mit denen die Ukraine in der Lage ist
tief in territor in russisches
Territorium vorzudringen das wäre hier
mit dem Flugzeugen ja der Fall das heißt
hier geht es jetzt nicht darum irgendwie
dem mit dem kleinen See zu testen wie
die Wassertemperatur ist sondern hier
geht es darum tatsächlich Risiken der
Eskalation einzuschätzen und
entsprechend zu handeln sie haben gerade
gesagt das geht ein bisschen so um die
Waffensysteme was empfindet Putin was
empfindet Russland dann als Bedrohung
jetzt ist in der Tat ähm ein Flugzeug
natürlich sehr mobil kann F16 eine der
stärksten kann Flugzeuge überhaupt er
kann natürlich viel ja viel bewegen im
wahrsten Sinn des Wortes auch mit mit
den mit den Waffen
jetzt gibt aber auch die Möglichkeit
eine Vereinbarung zu treffen dass sie
nur im ukrainischen Gebiet eingesetzt
werden können ist das etwas was dann die
großen beruhigt oder sagen die generell
wenn westliche Kampfflugzeuge kommen
haben wir eine völlig andere Situation
na das wäre die russische Seite auf
jeden Fall nicht beruhigen und ehrlich
gesagt bin ich erst selbst sehr
skeptisch das soll eine Vereinbarung
wirklich möglich ist wir haben in der
ukrainischen Führung unterschiedliche
Gruppen unterschiedliche Ansichten
gerade jetzt beobachten wir dass die
ukrainische Führung durchaus auch
interne machtkämpfer erlebt und da
jemand da eskaliert ist absolut nicht
ausgeschlossen dazu kommt das Russland
zu diesem Zeitpunkt genauso wenig
Vertrauen an den Westen hat wieder
Westen in Russland man wird nur an
Lieferungen schauen nicht an versprechen
jetzt war ja Thomas Wiegold ich habe
gerade schon angesprochen die
Flugzeugtypen die die Bundeswehr benutzt
also Eurofighter und Tornados spielen da
erstmal keine Rolle die Franzosen haben
ja auch nicht ausgeschlossen Kampf
Flugzeuge zu schicken der Typ heißt Fall
den die Franzosen verwenden warum gerade
die F16 wieso oder die Ukraine hatte
ganz offenbar konkret deine Bestellungen
Anführungszeichen aufgegeben warum
gerade dieses Flugzeug also wir haben
eine veränder in der Debatte wir hatten
eine flugzeugdebatte Kampfflugzeug
Debatte vor einem Jahr also ziemlich
nein das noch was anderes da komme ich
gleich auch noch drauf wir hatten eine
Debatte über MiG 29 die alten
sowjetischen Abfangjäger die Polen zum
Beispiel hat und Polen hat gesagt die
schenken wir der Ukraine auf dem Umweg
über Rammstein haben die USA gesagt das
machen wir nicht die mit 29 ist ein
reiner Abfangjäger der wäre dazu da
gewesen russische Flugzeuge aus
ukrainischem Territorium zu vertreiben
jetzt haben wir eine andere Debatte die
F16 ist ein Mehrzweckkampfflugzeug vor
allem dazu geeignet mit Bomben und lenke
Flughafen Ziel am Boden anzugreifen das
will die Ukraine zur Unterstützung
Stichwort Gefechte verbundenen Waffen
mit Panzern mit Schützenpanzern mit
Artillerie also sie möchte sozusagen die
Luftwaffe als Unterstützung ihrer Boden
mal gucken jetzt müssen wir aber auch
eins sehen zu einem erfolgreichen
Vorgehen gehört dann auch dass die
gegnerische Flugabwehr ausgeschaltet
wird suppression of anime erdefence
wegbomben der gegnerischen Flugabwehr
die sitzt aber in Russland und dann sind
wir genau bei den Problemen was er liebt
man angesprochen hat um erfolgreich
vorgehen zu können kennt könnte die
Ukraine gar nicht anders als Ziel in
Russland anzugreifen mit diesem
Flugzeugen das heißt die mit 29 ist
eigentlich fast wertlos weil sie nur
eine Monostruktur hat in Form eines
Abfangjägers den braucht man ja auch
Russland kaum noch Flugzeuge in die
Ukraine schickt auch wegen der Gefahr
des Abschusses aber die F16 ist
eigentlich auch wertlos man denn die
Ukraine könnten ja diese Forderung die
zum Beispiel macron gestellt hat ihr
kriegt unsere Flugzeuge wenn überhaupt
nur dann wenn ihr die nicht in Russland
einsetzt der eigentlich auch gar nicht
erfüllen das heißt also diese Diskussion
geht über um Optionen die gar nicht so
etwa so auf die Formel könnte man es
bringen und das erklärt auch warum der
besten so zögert bleibt die Diskussion
uns ja wahrscheinlich trotzdem erhalten
die Frage ist ja auch wie sinnvoll sie
im Moment ist und ob da sich gerade
etwas aufschaukelt aber bleiben wir mal
dabei dass diese Forderungen der Ukraine
ja im Raum steht wer käme denn außer den
USA noch als Lieferant dieser F16 in
Frage ganz Reihe von NATO Ländern haben
diese Maschine ja auch zum Teil in
größerer Stückzahl gibt es da Länder die
da eher bereit wären oder
würde das dann
ja Frage wer dann liefert
also
Polen und die Niederlande haben ja schon
sehr deutlich gemacht dass Sie sich das
vorstellen können
es gibt ja auch noch diesen Hinweis dass
man eigentlich nur mit der F16 richtig
gut vorgehen kann gegen die Russen ist
diese Verbundenheit dieser verbundenen
Einsatz sie haben es ja gesagt damit
kann man Ziele am Boden gekämpfen das
ist ja umgekehrt auch für die Leopard
Panzer wichtig die ja ihre Stärken nur
dann ausspielen können wenn sie mit den
Flugzeugen und der Artillerie zusammen
davor gehen können das heißt umgekehrt
Panzer ohne Flugzeuge ist auch nicht so
gut also
der kommt darauf an wie sie genau gut
oder nicht gut definieren und das ist
für mich gerade der große Unterschied
zwischen beiden in dieser Debatte in
Deutschland merke ich eigentlich keine
strategische Debatte mit der klaren
Definition dessen was Deutschland und
konkrete Deutschland eigentlich will in
den USA gibt es diese Debatte es werden
verschiedene Interessen abgewogen und
das bedeutet dass einfach nicht alles
was Ukraine antwortet im amerikanischen
Interesse ist zu liefern und ein großer
Krieg gegen Russland ist nicht immer
amerikanischen Interesse dementsprechend
werden auch wenige effiziente Lösungen
zu Unterstützung der Ukraine eingesetzt
auch diese strategische Debatte nicht
gibt hier bei uns liegt das daran dass
die Europäer dass das so so ein gemischt
für Anlagen oder manchmal auch ein
ziemlich
aufgescheuchte Haufen ist oder wird
diese
strategische Diskussion in Deutschland
auch aus innenpolitischen Gründen nicht
gern geführt also ich glaube das ist ein
zweiter Problem wir haben
ganz kurz
also weil wir natürlich in der EU
einfach im Vergleich zu den USA das
Problem haben dass wir mehr als ein mehr
als ein Land haben und man sich
natürlich da einigen muss und alleine
auch durch unterschiedliche historische
geographische wirtschaftliche politische
Zusammenhänge sehr unterschiedliche
Interessen in der EU vorhanden sind und
nicht aber das können wir eben auch
nicht weg diskutieren das ist sehr
schwer sich dazu einigen ich glaube aber
auch dass wir in
Deutschland ein Problem haben
strategisch über militärische Fragen zu
reden was auch historisch bedingt ist
ich glaube aber auch dass das ein Stück
weit an der
hat er Debatte in im letzten Jahr liegt
wo wir uns so Salami Taktik mäßig vor
bewegt haben und wir haben was wir haben
wir haben etwas gemacht wir haben
bestimmte Art von Waffen geliefert und
gleichzeitig gesagt was wir nicht machen
als legitimationshilfe dafür nur um das
dann wieder Zeitenwende ist noch
ziemlich auf dem Weg also da sind wir
noch nicht so weit vorgekommen weil sie
sagen diese Diskussion die müssen wir
uns erstmal angewöhnen darüber rational
wir müssen uns fragen genau was soll man
sagt was sind unsere Ziele in der
Ukraine also bis zu welchem Punkt wollen
wir die Ukraine unterstützen und dann
würde sich ja auch rückwärts definieren
lassen welche Art von Unterstützung
wieder Ukraine geben aber weil man eben
diese Diskussion scheut sicherlich aus
ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen ist das
aus meiner Sicht eben auch sehr schwer
und das gibt für dann in diesem
scheibchenweise Vorgehen was wir über
das letzte Jahr sehen
ja ich wollte einmal dazu stellen weil
ich ich würde diesen Eindruck nicht
unbedingt teilen ich würde sagen dass
diese strategische Debatte in
Deutschland geführt wird und das ja auch
die Regierung sehr deutlich gemacht hat
was sie eben nicht bereit ist in Kauf zu
nehmen und das ist eine Eskalation das
heißt eine Entgrenzung dieses Konfliktes
über die Ukraine hinaus also die
Konfrontation mit Russland das ist die
gleiche Debatte die in den USA auch
geführt wird dass man sie dort
vielleicht teilweise explizite und
offensiver führt auch offensiv darüber
redet eben dieses Risiko und Kauf zu
nehmen okay das hat mit
unterschiedlichen strategischen Kulturen
zu tun aber die Debatte wird in
Deutschland auch geführt und die ähm
diese Bezeichnung der bisherigen Taktik
und das finde ich völlig verständlich
als Salami Taktik stimmt natürlich auf
der anderen Seite haben wir in den
letzten Minuten jetzt die ganze Zeit
darüber geredet man müsste ja zögerlich
sein mit den kampflugzeugen weil man ja
das eskalationsrisiko nicht völlig
irgendwie hängt anstellen kann aber wenn
das so ist dann ist natürlich eine
Salamitaktik geboten in ja man Schritt
für Schritt vorgeht auf Sicht fährt und
schaut was bestimmte Entscheidungen denn
bei den Kriegsparteien auslösen wie sie
sich im Feld sozusagen materialisieren
bevor man weitere Entscheidungen trifft
dann ist das also eigentlich eine
strategisch kluge Praxis die man da
beobachten kann
also Olaf Scholz vorgehen würden sie da
als ja als richtig empfinden
also ich würde zumindest sagen dass
diese Art des zögerlichen durchaus eine
Berechtigung hat die Art wie darüber
kommuniziert wurde finde ich alles
andere als optimal aber die eigentliche
Strategie zu sagen wir gehen nicht
All-In wir schmeißen nicht alles rein
was wir haben um die Ukraine irgendwie
zum Sieg zu bewegen sondern wir schauen
bei jeder Entscheidung die wir getroffen
haben erstmal was passiert vor Ort was
hat das eigentlich für Auswirkung die
finde ich schon angesichts der
Ausgangslage sehr klug ich wollte wieder
sprechen also ich habe so ein bisschen
das Problem jeder Schritt der dann doch
gegangen wurde war erst eine drohte eine
Eskalation zu sein 5000 Helme welche
Eskalation Thriller Flugabwehrraketen
aus dem Depot welcher istkalation
Panzerhaubitze welcher Eskalation mache
da welche Eskalation Leo welcher
Eskalation und jetzt haben wir einen
Punkt der wirklich die Gefahr einer
Eskalation in sich birgt und dann glaubt
einem doch keiner mehr weil jeder
Schritt vorher
jede Patrone war eine Eskalation
genau und das ist für mich deswegen gibt
es keine eskalationsrisiko mehr nein das
sage ich ja nicht sondern das
eskalationsrisiko ist nach wie vor da
wir können es eben nicht vorhersagen und
das heißt wir müssen natürlich
vorsichtig vorgehen da bleibt uns doch
gar keine andere Wahl nicht selbst
abschrecken nicht gar nichts machen aber
natürlich müssen wir bei jedem Schritt
immer wieder neu nachdenken und prüfen
das ist genau für mich die Abwesenheit
der strategischen Debatte sie haben
absolut recht es gibt gewisse
strategische Vorstellungen die von
Teilen der Bundesregierung leider aber
eben nur von Teilen geteilt werden aber
es gibt keine systematische Diskussion
in der deutschen Gesellschaft die
wirklich ganz klar auf Interessen und
konkrete Ziele gerichtet wäre und da ist
die strategische Deeskalation einfach
nicht das einzige was man diskutieren
muss da geht's auch zum Beispiel darum
in den USA wird jetzt ganz offen und
ganz offensiv diskutiert was bedeutet
ein sehr langer Krieg was bedeuten zum
Beispiel die Entwicklungen in der
Ukraine selbst darüber muss man einfach
systematisch reden und das erwarten von
Deutschland übrigens auch europäischen
Verbündeten weil dann verstehen Sie auch
wofür Deutschland steht dessen muss man
nicht scheuen sondern offensiv angehen
muss man denn diese ganze Frage Frau
pagoon auch unter dem Aspekt ziehen dass
man jetzt sowohl die Waffenlieferungen
auch wie mögliche Idee Eskalation auch
die Stärkung der Ukraine nach dem Krieg
um die
um die Russen davon abzuhalten noch mal
versuchen in die Ukraine
einzumarschieren auch mittel und
langfristig sehen das heißt also ein
Konzept gerade wir sind jetzt bei den
Waffen ja ähm Panzer Flugzeuge in einer
Mittel- und langfristigen Dimension dass
man die Ukraine zwar Stärken muss mit
diesen Waffen aber nicht alles auf
einmal sondern jetzt in einer nicht nur
was den Krieg jetzt angeht je nachdem
wie lange der dauern wird sondern auch
für Zeiten nach dem Krieg also ich
glaube das stecken zwei Aspekte drin
also zum einen ja wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass dieser Krieg noch lange
dauern wird also müssen mittel bis
langfristig militärische Planungen
vorhalten und wir müssen uns auch
darüber Gedanken machen dass unabhängig
wann dieser Krieg endet oder in welch ja
oder welchen Teil du ukrainischen
Territoriums hier auf aktuell
kontrolliert das ist wahrscheinlich
darauf hinauslaufen wird dass man diesen
Teil mit militärisch so sichern muss
dass es für Russland einfach erfolglos
ist nochmal gegen die Ukraine vorzugehen
ich glaube die andere Frage ist aber
eben auch noch mal die da Planung und
ich glaube das ist eben auch das
Spannungsverhältnis in indem man sich
befindet auch noch mal in Bezug auf das
raus Frau weitlauf gesagt hat also ja
das einerseits auf Sicht fahren
andererseits ist es aber natürlich so
dass Debatten dauern und dann Logistik
Lieferung etc auch noch mal dauert das
heißt wenn wir jetzt die Debatte z.B
hatten jetzt braucht die Ukraine Panzer
ist es eigentlich eine Debatte die wir
hätten mindestens von einem halben Jahr
führen müssen dass sie rechtzeitig ein
Ukraine ankommt und das ist natürlich
ein großes Problem vor Ort wenn sie
einfach diesen ganzen Prozess so
verzögern und damit natürlich auch die u
Sinne in einem militärisch ermutige
Position bringt weil dann in dem Moment
nicht an das rankommt was sie eigentlich
bräuchtet zu Selbstverteidigung und da
ist das ist natürlich eine normale
Spannungsverhältnis zwischen ich schaue
vielleicht was passiert ich schaue
vielleicht auch auf die öffentliche
Meinung in Deutschland und ich schaue
auf die Bedürfnisse
der Außenpolitik selber und das ist ja
etwas was wir häufig sehen Außenpolitik
wird häufig weniger daraus gedacht was
außenpolitisch notwendig ist oder Ziel
ist sondern eher aus innenpolitischen
Bedürfnisse ich über den Begriff
öffentliche Meinung aus dem was Frau
bakuum gerade gesagt hat mal aufgreifen
das ist ja der eigentliche Unterschied
zu Russland hier gibt es eine offene
Diskussion eine offene Gesellschaft an
dieser Diskussion beteiligen sich viele
viel mehr als früher zu diesem Thema die
Politik wird auch zum Teil unter Druck
gesetzt zumindestens kann man Olaf
Scholze bei den anderen vermuten dass
sie natürlich auch schauen wie die
Bevölkerung das aufnimmt und welche
Ängste da z.B da sind in Russland gibt
es alles nicht
da gibt es eine kontrollierte
Information wenn überhaupt
erlebt man weiß ich jetzt gesagt haben
die mit dem kampfschätzen ist natürlich
auch Thomas Wiegold hat es ja bestätigt
vielleicht dann doch etwas eine Art eine
andere Qualität wie empfindet denn die
russische Bevölkerung so etwas wenn der
Westen jetzt die Ukraine stark auf
mediziniert mit modernsten Waffen die
noch nicht mal russland hat die haben
zwar ein großer Zahl Waffen aber nicht
von der Schlagkraft
könnte es sein dass die die Abneigung
gegen den Westen gegen alles westliche
dadurch nur verstärkt wird oder nicht
nur durch russische Propaganda sondern
auch durch das eigene Empfinden das ist
auf jeden Fall der Fall und ich glaube
das soll Teil der strategischen Debatte
sein weil man muss auch darüber
nachdenken was nach dem Krieg mit
Russland passiert und wie man mit
Russland interagieren wird die Debatte
die jetzt geführt wird in Russland von
vielen wahrgenommen nicht nur von der
Regierung als ein Zeichen dass der
Westen ganz klar gegen Russland
grundsätzlich vorgehen will wir haben
russische Soldaten der an der Front
sterben es werden mehr und mehr sterben
und unausweichlich werden in Russland
sich mehr und mehr Leute den besten als
strategischen Feind sehen und das ist
ein enorme Gefahr weil jetzt haben wir
tatsächlich einen Krieg den Putin und
eine kleine Gruppe um ihn herumführt
wenn das weiter so ein Jahr dauert oder
zwei Jahre dauert wird es ein Krieg sein
den Großteil der russischen Bevölkerung
unterstützt und dann ist die Lage viel
schlimmer aber das ist ja die genau das
Problem nach Schätzungen könnten es ja
bis zu 180.000 junge Männer gewesen sein
die seit dem letzten Jahr gestorben sind
und davon umgekommen sind aber die hat
doch Putin auf dem Gewissen also wenn
sie jetzt sagen wir müssen die
Diskussion führen auch im Hinblick auf
die empfinden das Empfinden der
russischen Bevölkerung
das stimmt und das ist auch ein Problem
für Putin ganz klar der auch von der
Seite derjenigen angegriffen wird
deutlich radikale in dem Krieg vorgehen
werden auch dies Argument verwenden aber
wir müssen nicht vergessen das Putin und
das ist nicht nur Teil von
Waffenlieferung der beiden das ist der
Teil von sanktionsdebatten die wir
hatten es wirklich sehr erfolgreich und
Russen vermittelt hat wir sind im Krieg
gegen den Westen der besten greift uns
grundsätzlich ein und dann sie haben
Recht aber es gibt auch ein narrativ in
Russland das Putin sehr effektiv
ausnutzen können Frau Titel auf sie sind
friedens- und konfliktforscherin da geht
es sicherlich jetzt auch darum es fragen
was wie können wir einerseits den Krieg
militärisch beenden das Ukraine dabei
nicht untergeht aber wie sieht diese
Nachkriegsordnung aus was muss man über
den militärischen Aspekt Hinblick auf
diese Frage berücksichtigen was könnte
man auch jetzt schon in diese jetzt auch
hier
diskutierte Strategie einfügen
ja sowas was uns natürlich umtreibt ist
tatsächlich wie kann man schon jetzt
dafür sorgen dass bestimmte Kanäle in
die russische Gesellschaft offen bleiben
dass wir also nicht in dieser
Konfrontation die ja auch mit
unglaublicher Brutalität geführt wird
alle Kanäle verschließen und dadurch uns
als Gesellschaft noch immer fremder
werden denn dann fehlen uns später auch
genau die Brücken über die man gehen
kann um neue Kontakte aufzubauen neues
Vertrauen zu stiften wenn dieser
Konflikt denn mal hinter uns liegt es
ist so und das wurde ja auch schon in
der Runde gesagt dass von all dem was
wir jetzt sehen was dort passiert in der
Ukraine wie er mit einem langen Krieg
rechnen das heißt auch mit einer nicht
Beendigung dieses Konfliktes mit nicht
festgelegten Grenzziehung sondern
stattdessen damit dass wir für die
nächsten Jahre vermutlich auf der einen
Seite Russland weiter in Schach halten
wollen weiter zurückbringen wollen und
auf der anderen Seite auch langfristig
die Ukraine militärisch ökonomisch und
finanziell unterstützen müssen dass sie
in der Lage ist sich gegen weitere
Übergriffe durch Russland zu verteidigen
in einer solchen Situation ist es
natürlich ausgesprochen schwierig diese
Kanäle offen zu halten man muss schon
jetzt überlegen was sind eigentlich
Anknüpfungspunkte man sieht das auch in
dieser Konfliktlage ist ja immer noch
direkte Gespräche zwischen den beiden
Regierungen gibt beispielsweise sehen
wir das eigentlich über die gesamte
Phase dieses Konfliktes
gefangenenaustausche relativ geräuschlos
und problemlos funktionieren wir haben
auch das getreideabkommen ich meine das
sind winzig kleine Bereich aber es sind
eben noch Zonen funktionierender
Kooperation und auf die kann man
natürlich auch setzen und versuchen von
da aus weitere Zonen von Kooperation
aufzubauen
für Waffenstillstand und
friedensverhandlung ist natürlich die
Situation für die Ukraine umso besser je
mehr militärischen Erfolg sie hat wenn
wir noch mal zu den Kampfflugzeugen
zurückkommen sind die unerlässlich für
die militärischen Ziele die die Ukraine
erreichen will bis zum Ende also nicht
nur das was seit dem 24 Februar verloren
hat sondern sie will ja auch Donbass und
die Krim zurückerobern zumindestens
militärisch neutralisieren das ist ja
auch eine Möglichkeit braucht man dazu
dann auch letztendlich diese Flugzeuge
damit die Ukraine die Kriegsziele
erreichen kann die Sie in die Lage
versetzt auf Augenhöhe mit Russland
Verhandlungen zu führen also ich würde
mal so sagen es ist sehr wahrscheinlich
ich würde es nicht auf Kampfflugzeuge
beschränken sondern weiter reichende
Waffen im Moment ist ja so Schluss bei
80 km Reichweite der raketenartillerie
die die Ukraine hat es ist jetzt im
Gespräch bestätigt ist es noch nicht
etwas weiterreichende 150 km die Ukraine
hätte gern Raketen die 300 km weit
reichen also so etwas und Flugzeuge das
ist das was ein Unterschied machen würde
und genau das was auch das
Eskalationspotenzial birgt weil es eben
nicht nur bis zur Krim reicht sondern
auch nach Belgrad nach Kurs und weiß ich
nicht damit Kampfjets die russische
Luftwaffenbasis Engels angegriffen wird
ist das für Russland ich weiß nicht ob
ich mich da täusche aber ein anderer
Qualität als wenn eine Drohne dorthin
fliegt also es ist zwar sachlich nicht
unterschiedlich ob unbemannt oder
bemannt aber aus der russischen
Wahrnehmung ist glaube ich ein Kampfjet
Angriff auf Engels der Super-GAU es gab
ja glaube ich schon einen also zumindest
den Verdacht dass eine ukrainische oder
mehrere Drohnen dort einen
Luftwaffenstützpunkt angegriffen haben
aber eben Drohnen genau nicht wenn man
genau zunächst mal gab es wenn wir auf
die weiteren Infrastruktur sprechen wir
enges tatsächlich nur für einzelte
Angriffe wenn systematischer wird als
auch eine andere Qualität auch mit
Drohnen sein zweitens mit Drohnen ist
die Situation immer deutlich unklarer
als mit den Flugzeugen bei Flugzeugen
ist es eindeutig ist es der ukrainische
Eingriffe da gibt's keine Doppel
Diskussion und das dritte dass ich auch
unbedingt wenn er muss ist es gibt
überhaupt keine Garantie das heißt die
Ukraine diese
Systeme hat keine zivilen Ziele in
Russland auch Untergeschoss kommen auch
wenn die Ukraine das nicht will es ist
Krieg und es kann passieren und sobald
sowas passiert eigentlich an der
Grenzlinie sterben auch in Russland
jeden Tag Menschen wenn es aber im
größeren Ausmaß weiter von der
Frontlinie passiert haben wir wieder
eine Lage wo Eskalationen extrem
wahrscheinlich ist um Ihnen ein Beispiel
zu geben wie Putin das schon heute
ausnutzen seiner Propaganda wir haben
Berichte dass in Moskau auf den
hochgebäuden die
Luftabwehrsysteme installiert wurden und
das verteilt sich alles im Internet ja
man will den Russen zeigen sie sind
bedroht das heißt wie Frau BAG um die
mehr Waffen der Ukraine überlassen
werden von westlichen Staaten egal
welche Waffenart umso mehr könnten sie
auch benutzt werden für militärische
Ziele die nicht im Sinne des Westens
sind ist man kann da vertraglich
Abmachungen machen aber wie schätzen Sie
das ein die ukrainische Führung wenn Sie
diese Waffen hat wird sie sich
an diese Vereinbarungen halten oder sagt
sie eigentlich haben wir jetzt die
Möglichkeit tatsächlich unsere Links
Ziele zu erreichen und versuchen
möglicherweise diese Abmachung mit dem
Westen zu unterlaufen also ich glaube in
der Tat dass das aktuell kein
drohendes Thema ist auch weil der Fokus
der Ukraine erstmal darauf liegt das
ukrainische Territorium zurück zu
erobern
man würde natürlich aber solche
Lieferungen solche Abmachungen auch
langfristig treffen und das ist glaube
ich das was eben Unsicherheit reinbringt
weil es die Frage was ist ein fünft was
ist in 10 oder was ist in 15
Jahren und ich glaube das sind Fragen
die da rein spielen ich würde einfach
trotzdem sagen dass
ist natürlich sehr sehr schwierig ist
sich für die Ukraine auf diese Weise zu
verteidigen wenn sie einfach bestimmte
militärische militärstrategische Aspekte
nicht nutzen kann oder also hey wie Gold
hat es ja erklärt wenn sie sich eben
absichern müssen gegen die zahlreichen
Angriffe mit mit Raketen die natürlich
von russischen vom Villa russischen
Territorium abgeschossen werden ist das
ein großes Problem ich glaube man könnte
das zeitweise auffangen auch durch eine
verbesserte Flug Abwehr aber ich glaube
diese Diskussion wird uns die nächste
Zeit begleiten sie kocht jetzt gerade
noch mal sehr hoch anhand anhand der der
Kampfjets aber es ist eben wie werden
immer wieder austarieren müssen wo
verläuft ihre Mutterlinie auch und ich
glaube das ist auch immer wichtiger wir
reden immer von roten Linien die Frage
ist sind diese roten Linien in Stein
gemeißelt und sind sie fest oder sind
sie nicht auch etwas was beweglich ist
was ich über Zeit verschieben kann was
ich auch in russischer Sicht verschiebt
je nach welche Möglichkeiten
strategischen Interessen Ressource oder
Ressourcen oder auch Zwänge hat also ich
glaube wir sollten auch ein bisschen
davon Abstand nehmen diese ja diese
roten Linien so tief rein zu graben
sondern immer zu schauen was was genau
ist die Debatte welche anderen Optionen
rote Linien
ja fragt sich jetzt wenn ich kritisieren
möchte dass es ohnehin fragt sich welche
begriff ich dann nehmen sollte aber also
verstanden dass ich die Politik gerade
in Deutschland dadurch immer selbst
behindert und selbstschwierigkeiten
bereitet mit dem Einziehen von roten
Linien dieser Begriffe der hier häufiger
benutzt vor allen Dingen von denjenigen
diejenigen denen die Waffenlieferungen
zu gehen ich glaube also ich glaube da
gibt es noch mal zwei unterschiedlich
das eine ist die Debatte
wo wo ist die Schwelle wo wir ein sehr
hohe eskalationsrisiko von russischer
Seite
vermuten ich glaube das ist die eine
Frage die andere Frage ist glaube ich
wie vermitteln wir die aktuellen
Entscheidungen der Bundesregierung in
der Bevölkerung und das was wir im
letzten Jahr ja gesehen haben war er
erstmal ist keine Waffen sondern nur
Helme dann waren es und defensiv Waffen
und keine offensiver auf mein Mann so
leichte Waffen und keine und ja ich weiß
also auch wenn es das nicht gibt aber es
wäre das was er was was was einfach
medial da war dann war es nur leichte
Waffen keine schweren Waffen dann waren
es alles andere aber keine Panzer dann
nur Schützenpanzer aber keine
Kampfpanzer und ich glaube man hat diese
Abgrenzung immer gemacht um eine
Legitimation oder Bevölkerung zu
erreichen ja wir machen jetzt das aber
das machen wir nicht und damit ja baut
man natürlich einen Sound auf oder
Pflanzen Baum auf die man dann immer am
Ende wieder auf klettern muss und das
ist glaube ich auch das was
die ganze Debatte im letzten Jahr sehr
schwierig gemacht hat und die ist meiner
Meinung nach nicht zwingend oder diesmal
meiner Meinung nach gar nicht unbedingt
damit verknüpft was man denkt wo die
roten Linien in Russland sind weil sie
sind waren sicherlich zu keinem
Zeitpunkt zwischen leichten und schweren
Waffen das glaube ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht die Frage ist ja jetzt nicht nur
wie gefährlich wie wirksam wie kritisch
sind diese Waffen es ist ja auch die
Frage wie sinnvoll sind
Waffenlieferungen
gefechtshelme also Schutzhelme die
können Sie in wenigen Sekunden aufsetzen
das geht relativ schnell Ausbildung an
Gewehren Handfeuerwaffen geht auch
schnell Panzer Tower dauert ein bisschen
länger Kampflugzeuge ich glaube die
Bundeswehr hat fünf Jahre angesetzt für
die Ausbildung nun werden ukrainische
Piloten ja schon in Flugzeugen
ausgebildet aber wie lange würde das
eigentlich dauern worüber reden wir
welche Zeiträume dass das wirklich wenn
man es denn wollte auch Luftwaffe
effektiv eingesetzt werden kann für mich
etwas schwer das zu sagen gucken weil
das entscheidende sind glaube ich nicht
die Monate oder Wochen die die Piloten
brauchen das entscheidende sind die
Monate oder ich weiß nicht genau wie
lange die die Techniker brauchen die
Instandhaltung für jede Stunde die ein
Kampfjet in der Luft ist haben sie
etliche Stunden am Boden wo er gewartet
wird an ihm geschraubt wird und da haben
wir das Problem ich glaube das ist viel
mehr ein Engpass als die Piloten die er
schon Erfahrungen im Luftkampf haben auf
anderen Mustern um zu schulen auf eine
solche Maschine und da kommen wir ein
anderes Problem was in der Debatte am
Rande gestreift wird wenn ein deutscher
Panzer oder eine deutsche Panzerhaubitze
kaputt ist
dann wird sie auf den Laster gepackt und
in die Slowakei gefahren da sitzen
Techniker der Deutschen Herstellerfirma
die Schrauben dran und dann geht es
zurück wenn ein Flugzeug einen Schaden
hat noch fliegen kann was machen Sie sie
fliegen es irgendwo hin wo es gewartet
wird nach Polen in die Slowakei und dann
starten westliche Kampfjets von einem
nato-flugplatz mit ukrainischen Piloten
und fliegen wieder ins Kampfgebiet
das ist dann zwar technisch gesehen nur
zur Wartung aber pardon es sieht doch so
aus wie die kommen aus der NATO und da
ist die NATO dann mit dabei das halte
ich für erheblich schwerwiegender als
die Frage ob der Pilot schnell genug ins
neue Cockpit eingewiesen werden kann
also die genau diese Debatte wie schnell
lernen ukrainische Soldaten und Soldaten
in bestimmten Geräten umzugehen die
hatten wir ja auch schon im Frühjahr bei
der panzerhaube zu wenn ich mich wenn
ich mich mich bei jedem System und ich
glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht dass das
also vor allen Dingen wenn man davon
ausgehen dass sie sonst krieg
möglicherweise noch länger begleiten
wird müssen wir ja auch langfristig
planen und ich glaube wenn dann ist die
Frage ob wir damit anfangen nicht davon
abhängig wieder gebrauchen die bis sie
das gelernt haben sondern halten wir es
für sinnvoll dass diese Waffen geliefert
werden aus
gemischt aus dem welches Ziel wollen wir
erreichen und welches Risiko wollen wir
verhindern wenn wir dann zu der
Entscheidung kommen Waffensystem x
sollte geliefert werden da sollten mit
der Ausbildung anfangen also für mich
ist dieses ausbildungsargument ehrlich
gesagt
ein bisschen in
ablenkungsargument um nicht auf die
Antwort nicht auf die Frage antworten zu
müssen weil wir das jetzt machen oder
nicht wobei natürlich unsere
Entscheidungen unsere Ziele auch
temporär abgegrenzt sind also es geht
nicht darum dass die Ukraine gewisse
Ziele irgendwann erreicht sondern es
geht um ganz konkrete Zeiträume und da
wird schon Ausbildungs wartungsargument
wichtig wenn man jetzt die Ukraine
ausrüstet in dem gewisse Ziele in fünf
Jahren erreicht werden dann muss man
auch verstehen was diese fünf Jahre
Krieg für die Ukraine für die
ukrainische Bevölkerung für Europa für
Deutschland für die Welt bedeutet und
das muss Teil der Debatte sein Gut
möglicherweise dauert dieser Krieg auch
fünf Jahre Verteilung ich würde gerne
eine grundsätzliche Frage noch stellen
die dieser Ukraine dieser
völkerrechtswidrige Angriff auf die
Ukraine hat ja den Begriff Frieden
schaffen ohne Waffen vielleicht nicht
absurden geführt aber doch schwer mal
trittiert heute würde man vielleicht
sagen
man sollte nicht aus allen Schwertern
Pflugscharen machen sondern sie als
Schwerter belassen damit man sich
verteidigen kann und ja nicht nur das
Land verteidigt sondern auch Freiheit
Demokratie Rechtsstaat Wohlstand muss
man da nicht generell in der ganzen
Konfliktforschung auch Umdenken was hat
das jetzt für unsere Wahrnehmung von
Konflikten von militärischen Konflikten
für Folgen in Deutschland ist man ja
jahrzehntelang sozusagen um alle
Probleme herumgefahren möglichst und hat
das die anderen machen lassen was
bedeutet er in dieser Hinsicht
grundsätzlich dieser dieser Angriff auf
die Ukraine auch gerade für die
Diskussion in der deutschen Gesellschaft
ja ich glaube Sie haben es jetzt schon
zum Schluss ganz gut gesagt was bedeutet
das für die deutsche Gesellschaft denn
ich würde die friedens- und
Konfliktforschung der gar nicht
herausnehmen als besonders schweren Fall
oder ähnliches sondern sagen das ist
etwas ist was die ganze Gesellschaft
betrifft und was ein Umdenken verursacht
hat was aber auch noch im Gange ist wir
haben lange uns der Illusion hingegeben
dass wir umgeben sind von Freunden und
uns eigentlich um das militärische nicht
mehr so kümmern müssen und eben Experten
für Kooperation und Meditation sind und
jetzt lernen wir dass es natürlich
Aggressoren in dieser Welt gibt die sich
überhaupt nicht dafür interessieren ob
wir Normen und Regeln und Institutionen
haben die doch verbieten mit
gewaltgrenzen zu verschieben die ist
einfach dennoch machen weil sie glauben
damit durchzukommen und da haben sie
schon recht helfen uns nicht in jedem
Fall sozusagen einen einen Sit-in
dagegen sondern da müssen wir eben
teilweise tatsächlich uns auch
militärisch verteidigen das müssen wir
wieder lernen das bedeutet natürlich
auch dass wir dafür anderes vielleicht
nicht im gleichen realisieren können
also dass wir eben auch mehr investieren
müssen in die Verteidigung dass wir uns
mehr mit diesen Fragen beschäftigen
müssen strategische Debatte war schon
hier ein Stichwort wichtig ist nur dass
wir eben nicht ins andere extreme
umschlagen und das haben wir auch
manchmal in der Debatte zu diesem Krieg
erlebt in der dann plötzlich nur noch
das militärische im Vordergrund stand
und nur noch die Frage wie können wir
schneller mehr und größere Waffen in die
Ukraine bekommen das ist auch nicht
sinnvoll es geht darum neu zu überlegen
wie wir in Zukunft Verteidigung also
militärische Sicherheit und die nicht
militärische Sicherheit kooperative
zivile Maßnahmen miteinander so
verbinden können dass wir eine neue
Friedensordnung nach diesem Krieg der ja
irgendwann enden wird aufbauen können
wenn die Balance da liegt man zwischen
militärischen und zivilen aus dem Tritt
gekommen
aus meiner Sicht schon das liegt aber
auch daran dass unsere Debatte jetzt
tatsächlich sehr emotional geläuft
angesichts der Grausamkeit und der
Brutalität des Krieges und da ist es
wirklich sehr schwierig eine Balance zu
halten das ist aber gerade aufs Gesicht
der Grausamkeit und der schrecklichen
Realitäten des Krieges umso wichtiger
dass man tatsächlich über alle Optionen
nachdenkt dass man diplomatien nicht
außer Acht lässt sondern als nach wie
vor klare und wichtige Teil von Mix von
Tools betrachtet die eingesetzt werden
kann sich den Wladimir Putin bei der
angenommenen Frühjahrsoffensive einen
weiteren militärischen Rückschlag wie
letzten Sommer leisten erstens bin ich
gar nicht sicher dass es so eine
offensive kommt das ist völlig unklar
das hängt wieder davon ab wie Putin
seine strategischen Ziele definiert und
da wird auch die ganze Zeit das Umdenken
passieren und zweitens Russland ist ein
autoritäres System und ich gehe davon
aus dass Russland noch sehr lange ein
Krieg führen kann solange gewisse rote
Linien tatsächlich entschuldigen Sie den
Begriff nicht überschritten werden
Angriff aufs russische Territorium auf
die Krim die Putin stemmen kann und die
Putins Regime stemmen kann aber die
Frage war ja nach einer militärischen
Auseinandersetzung bei der Russland
Rückzüge also ein Rückzug machen muss
den es nicht machen will möglicherweise
im Kampf
militärisch deklassiert wird kann sich
eine Putin einen weiteren Rückschlag
noch erlauben also Definition des
militärischen es gibt eine objektive es
gibt den Krieger es gibt auch die
Propaganda Wahrnehmung und Propaganda
nehmen kann ziemlich einiges umdeuten
und das haben wir auch gesehen was kann
natürlich passieren dass dann Russland
auf militärisch und das ist für mich
ehrlich gesagt eine wichtige Debatte als
das ob das Putin verkraften kann oder
nicht das als Reaktion auf militärischem
militärischen Niederlage oder etwas als
in Russland ist militärischen Niederlage
wahrgenommen kann noch auf eine
unvorhersageweise eskaliert das hat
Putin eigentlich nachhaltig gemacht mit
den Angriffen auf ukrainische Energie
Infrastrukturen es geht nicht nur um
nuklearen Weg es gibt viele andere
schreckliche Stufen der Eskalation und
da kann tatsächlich deutlich mehr
passieren wenn man das mal als
russischen Kontrollverlust bezeichnet
wie müsste sich der West in einer
solchen Situation dann verhalten wenn es
tatsächlich eine Situation gibt man
nicht weiß wie Putin jetzt reagiert
jetzt würde man ja sagen der ist ja
nicht wahnsinnig und setzt Atomwaffen
ein aber was wird in einer solchen wenn
sich wirklich eine verheerende
Niederlage Russlands abzeichnet wie
müsste sich dann der Westen in dieser
Situation verhalten die Frage was ist
eine verhandelnde was ist eine
verhandelnde Niederlage ich glaube das
ist die das ist die das ist die Krux
also wir haben ja bis jetzt auch gesehen
dass Russland durchaus schon sehr
deutliche Niederlagen eingesteckt hat
und das eben nicht dazu geführt hat dass
man entweder von Kriegszielen ablässt
oder dass ich ja irgendeine Form von von
Eliten Zersplitterung oder auch von von
Schwächung des Systems innerhalb
Russlands abzeichnet und die Frage ist
ab welchem Punkt würde es so weit kommen
also ich glaube ehrlich gesagt dass die
Ukraine gerade außerhalb der Krim noch
relativ viel auch zurückerobern konnte
ohne dass es soweit kommt dann die
zentrale Frage ist ja am Ende welche
Interessen haben die Eliten in Russland
an diesem System festzuhalten
und solange sie sich glaube ich davon
mehr versprechen als von einem möglichen
ja Regime Wechsel Regime Zerfall der
natürlich ein großes Maß an Unsicherheit
mit sich bringt für diese Eliten ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie daran
festhalten sehr groß auch weil putin ist
natürlich sehr gut verstanden hat ein
System zu schaffen was von Misstrauen
von unterschiedlichen
informationsgehalten geprägt ist und ich
glaube darauf müssen wir eben ganz genau
schauen wie wie verhalten sich die
Eliten bilden sich gegen Eliten raus und
das Problem dass ihr daran natürlich
haben ist das aufgrund des Krieges
aufgrund des auch ja immer
verkrustete im Autoritarismus in
Russland wie immer weniger Einsicht
haben in das was wirklich in abgeht und
was die
was die debattenlinien überhaupt sind
und ich glaube das macht es eben auch
sehr sehr schwer zu beurteilen wann es
soweit ist und jetzt ihre eigentlichen
Frage
also wie muss der Westen sich verhalten
also ich glaube zum einen bei dem was
jetzt passiert also insbesondere die USA
Signal signalisieren natürlich sehr
deutlich
was drohen würde beispielsweise bei
einem Nuklearschlag auch anderen
Eskalationen das andere ist glaube ich
und das ist vor allen Dingen zentral
Moskau zielt darauf dass die
Unterstützung in Europa oder am besten
für die Ukraine nachlässt und das Moskau
die längeren Atem hat und ich glaube wir
müssen sehr deutlich machen dass das
eben nicht der Fall sein nicht der Fall
sein wird um zu verdeutlichen dass ein
etwaige Eskalation
einfach auch nichts bringen würde was
nicht heißt das nicht so weit kommt ist
diese Gefahren dass hier der das
Interesse und damit auch die
unterstützungs das unterstützungs
Engagement nachlässt also ich glaube
eigentlich nicht weil trotz einiger
Ausreißer Stichwort Ungarn oder so
Europa ja immer noch relativ
kompakt relativ geeint Auftritt bei
allen Differenzen was wir bei Panzern
gesehen haben was wir bei Kampfjet sehen
aber unterm Strich ist Europa schon sehr
einig und ich wollte noch einen Punkt
anfügen es gibt ja eine dicke rote Linie
um den Begriff jetzt doch noch mal zu
gebrauchen und zwar eine dicke rote
Linie die für Russland und für den
Westen identische ist ich beschreibt das
mal wertfrei wenn es einen russischen
Angriff auf die NATO gebe würde die NATO
nicht nur wie die Ukraine jetzt
Raketen abschießen und wie zurückerobern
sondern sie würde Basen in Russland
selbst nicht angreifen sie würde
versuchen die Standorte die Standorte
von Raketen Flugzeugen und so weiter
zu neutralisieren
Flotte all diese Dinge all das wird der
Ukraine gesagt darfst du nicht der
besten erwartet dass die Ukraine anders
sich verteidigt als es die NATO tun
würde eben damit Russland selber nicht
Ziel der Angriffe ist und da treffen
sich so verrückt das klingt der
russische und das westliche Interesse
damit es eben nicht zu diesem Konflikt
kommt wir werden diese Gedanken
fortschreiben wir sind nämlich am Ende
dieser Sendung also gedanklich bei die
kontakelhoff bei Sarah baguhn bei Thomas
Wiegold und bei Alexander Liebmann Liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer alles
hängt ja mit allem zusammen dass wenn
Sie auch morgen in der Phönix Runde
sehen mit dem Titel rekordination
Energiekrise zinshof wie steht die
deutsche Wirtschaft da
aktuelles auch in Phoenix der Tag mit
Thomas Bade auch da bleiben wir beim
Thema der Verteidigungsminister war auch
heute zu Besuch beim panzerparieren in
Augustdorf und dieses Panzerbataillon
spielt in der NATO-Strategie eine ganz
wichtige Rolle bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]